I know absolutely nothing you guys call
me home and I'm definitely gonna cry and
dad's gonna kill me
because it's customs I'm like ready but
[Music]
today a group of us who have been
mistaken for different races our whole
lives are finally getting our DNA tested
with 23andme to either confirm what we
know about our family history or find
out if there's actually something Chavez
guesses that people have made our whole
lives we're gonna send in our DNA
samples and in a few weeks we'll find
out our results a lot of people would
say that I'm from Colombia half black
half white and I've also been mistaken
recently for Russia that's a new one I
don't know people have assumed either
I'm Samoan I'm black Italy Israel
gazillion Mexican Asian Native Hawaiian
- Mexican Spanish Dominican Indian I've
been asked if I was black Porto Rican or
cute them Egyptian I've gotten Sri
Lankan Canadian me because I'm just a
nice people think I'm a Latino a lot or
just Mexican I've gotten some sort of
Asian Chinese or Korean or Japanese they
just don't know people just generally
think I'm not white a lot of people
think I'm Asian
specifically Filipino suddenly be like
whoa I don't know you spoke Spanish how
do you know how to speak Spanish so well
Armenian Russian Italian people often
think that I some form of latina other
than that people think that I'm mixed
French Chinese Japanese Laos and Korean
anything really I find that people
gravitate towards groups that they find
familiar I don't usually find that I
have a group I usually kind of feel out
of those circles I feel like there's a
lot of internal struggle where I fit in
exactly because when I hang out with my
Mexican family and I have this huge F
hair like I'm one of the only people
something it was kind of tough as a kid
got made fun of by white people for
being Asian got made fun of by Asian
people for being white gotten hit by
both for looking Latino when my facial
hair started growing in and younger
people like everything to be in neat
little boxes it makes you feel a little
bit alone
like you have nowhere that you belong
but my lady
and people would ask my mother if I was
adopted I always feel a little sad about
it but my mom would just be like oh they
just need to see her huh I feel like I
can connect to many different cultures a
lot easier being racially ambiguous I do
believe in the future that there will be
more racially ambiguous people in this
world all my life I haven't been told
much about my background because my
mom's white and my dad is black they've
had a lot of hardships
having me and being together since I was
born it was like we're an interracial
couple people are gonna say stuff about
it just live your life so it was never
really told much to me what I was
specifically it was more so like people
are gonna think you're weird because
you're mixed just go with it and let
people know that they're wrong I've
never been really interested in knowing
my background until recently I was like
maybe I should know because I'm half my
father so I'm going to be 50% African
but I'm sure he's not fully African
either on my mom's side maybe 27% Irish
23 % German I literally don't have a
clue my dad was single for a while he
meant a lot of other Korean people
through his job at the post office a
Korean pastor they all knew literally
said John I know a good woman in Korea
who needs a good man like you they were
writing letters back and forth for maybe
a year and it worked I had to break down
my ethnicity it would be 50% Korean
curious to see how much Japanese or
Chinese is also mixed in there my dad's
side I literally know nothing about the
European side of my heritage people
never see me interested in the European
part I'm actually very interested in
that I think 25 percent Irish 25 percent
English my father was born in China came
to the US when he was very young maybe
around five or six so I'm pretty sure
I'm 50% Chinese my parents met in a
hospital because my father was a doctor
and my mother was a nurse so my mom her
background is
Italian and polish I know that my
Italian family their name is in the
books at Ellis Island so I'll be 25%
Italian and 25% polish I've never been
to any of those places my dad was born
in Memphis Tennessee my mom was born in
New Jersey that's as far back the
history of Courtenay goes I don't think
I've been told him you think about my
family show you there
nor did I ask I feel like I broke your
brain when you were like what what do
you mean you don't know I'm not adopted
my mom died when I was 4 and so I was
raised by my dad and my grandparents and
my aunts and uncles I know nothing at
all but I have always been curious so
wild guess 30% African maybe another 30%
of some kind of European 10% maybe South
America kind of this the last 30%
unknown cuz I don't even know where else
would go on my dad's side we've been in
America for at least four generations
most of my mom said is actually not
around anymore it's hard for us to find
and get all these details at this point
at which we have so very little records
oh this is a complete wild guess like I
had no clue I'm probably 20% brazilian
15% Polish 15% Russian 20% Spanish 10%
African 10% Native American 10% of like
we just don't know I was born in Mexico
my mom and my dad were also born in
Mexico I want to do this because I have
a really strong connection with my
ancestors and I'd love to put a region
culture skin tone to lady's beings that
have guided me my whole life I had to
guess I'd probably say 50% Mexican or
Native American 25% European Spanish to
be specific 25% North African Moroccan
so both of my parents are from the
northern part of Mexico my
great-grandparents were born there
beyond that we actually don't really
know very much from the casual googling
I've done I know that there is a history
of Asian communities moving to Mexico
there is a slight chance that I have an
ancestor who might be Asian if I were to
take a guess I'd probably say 70%
indigenous Mexican 30% from Spain or
that general area because Mexico was
colonized by Spain
right now we're gonna collect our DNA
samples by spitting into a tube we're
going to send it off to 23andme and
we'll hear back in a few weeks
do me proud spit my name is Sam and Kona
esselman and I'm the content and
curation scientist on the ancestry team
here at 23andme so are you guys ready to
hear about your results do this so
Daniel what do you already know or think
you know about your heritage as far as I
understand my dad lived in Chicago and I
think his parents emigrated from the UK
I'm not actually sure he doesn't really
talk about it a lot Daniel you are 51.4%
East Asian and Native American and that
breaks down into 45.5% Korean good job
yeah I figured there'd be a little
something there you are 48.5% European
yeah Wow all right 46.5% is British and
Irish heritage
wait 1% Ashkenazi Jewish word word feel
like is the test good job man I didn't
think that the European half would be so
spot-on I've been telling the truth all
these years next we're moving on to
Courtney I'm nervous
me and Alison we're really hoping were
cousins or related in some way it's
gonna happen that we're excited anxious
to know the results you are actually
77.1% sub-saharan African my family does
not talk about it so I was just picking
up whatever cultures were around my
neighborhood now as I go yeah I'm part
of that I sprinkled in a little that of
your sub-saharan African heritage your
DNA has 70 2.9% West African 2.3 percent
African hunter-gatherer on top of that
you are 19.7% European 6.8% British and
Irish recent ancestry in the United
Kingdom 0.5% Iberian that's 0.3%
Scandinavian you're 1.8% East Asian and
Native American oh there's no
bring it all in everywhere baby 21.3%
Southeast Asian 0.3% Native American
0.1% Western Asian and North African
heritage specifically that 0.1% is North
African and Arabian I feel speechless
now would make sense why my family never
talked about it because don't nobody
know where we're from we're all over the
place I would have never imagined half
of it that was fun
so now we're moving on to Andrea oh my
god I'm nervous
my stomach's like I'm not I can't wait
to hear in terms of like genetics I
literally know nothing
you have 50.4% East Asian and Native
American 47.9% of that is Native
American recent ancestry in Mexico yeah
which is what you thought from knowing
where your grandparents lived 0.4%
Southeast Asian ancestry so cool there's
also 39.2% European ancestry 22.4%
iberian evidence of ancestry in Spain
0.4% Ashkenazi Jewish wow that's very
interesting point two percent Sardinian
0.1% Scandinavian we still got some more
you have 2.6 percent
sub-saharan African ancestry 1.6 percent
is West African and then you have 0.6%
Western Asian and North African DNA hope
that makes sense I feel kind of like
overwhelmed I've always had a really
strong connection with my ancestors they
often call on them make a very conscious
contact with them to hear that I have
like pretty recent ancestry and that is
indigenous to Mexico even goes as far as
like the other side of the world it just
makes me feel really supportive to know
that I can go to some of these countries
and connect with some of those energies
like a really sad part about Mexican
ancestry and Mexican culture that a lot
of records and histories have been
erased so one of those first kind of
like really big steps and figuring out
where our own ancestors came from and
where they met
imagining love stories I'm glad that
this is meaningful for you next we've
got one do you think there's anything
else in there I'm excited to learn more
you are in fact 45 point six percent
East Asian and Native American what
includes is 42.7% Native American with
evidence of lien recent ancestry in
Mexico the rest of that is 41.7%
European and of that 26.9% is Iberian
and that's again something like Spanish
or Portuguese in addition you are 0.6%
Balkan very cool
you also have 0.4%
Ashkenazi Jewish heritage cousin wait 1%
Sardinian heritage all I really knew is
that my ancestors were from Mexico there
was colonization that happened there so
I knew about yeah be Aryan and Native
American and we're not done yet
oh so you are also three point seven
percent sub-saharan African two percent
is West African it's actually really
common for Central and South America to
have a little bit of West African
heritage oh cool
awesome you also have one point seven
percent Western Asian and North African
one point two percent North African and
Arabian we're so related me did you
learn anything that you didn't know
before few percentages of sub-saharan
African it's so on my bucket list to
really dive deep into my ancestry this
is a really great start now we're gonna
look at Jason's ancestry um Jason what
do you know about your heritage we can
track back to maybe the 1500s when it
comes to before that we just existed I
really need to know there's a couple
twists on that you are 80.5% European oh
this is what I think might be a little
bit of a surprise to you you have 48.2%
Ashkenazi Jewish DNA so almost 50%
Ashkenazi Jewish whoa my family has a
long history of Judaism but I'm also
surprised that it showed up on this
we're still Jewish till this day 17.1%
Iberian Wow ok next you have 12.7%
sub-saharan african heritage 11.4% is
west african
okay point one percent is this African
hunter-gatherer heritage what there's
also four point seven percent East Asian
and Native American and that is almost
all Native American heritage
specifically and there is evidence of
recent ancestry in Brazil so you were
right about that this is so cool my
family only knows it by story it's
always been passed down as like oh we're
just our native here but that like we
have like no we have no proof of it this
is the confirmation of this moment like
this is it the evidence is in your DNA
oh this is so cool 2.1% unassigned and
that's just DNA matches many different
continents or many different parts the
world or we can't matches how it feels
glad to hear all of this actually kind
of proud my family has been able to both
keep track of our history but also
maintain some of it for so long we still
practice like that heritage till today I
couldn't even tell how many generations
that must have been but just like
knowing it we can look at different
ancestry show up throughout your genome
to kind of predict when these ancestors
might live an ancestor of yours who was
a hundred percent
Ashkenazi Jewish this person probably is
just one or two generations removed from
you so that was a Jewish orange between
1930 and 1960 yes I wouldn't know that
who in this Allison do you have any idea
about your ancestry you guys what if I'm
not Chinese though it dad's gonna kill
me
but now I'm nervous like maybe that's
not true
you've got a long list welcome to the
long list Club oh my goodness I'm like
nervous I'm gonna throw up dude somebody
have a bucket no I'm fine I'm fine
oh geez you're doing like in the splash
zone five we're sitting up here yeah I'm
ready let's do it you are in fact
exactly 50% East Asian and Native
American and of that actually only
thirty seven point seven percent is
identified with our algorithm as Chinese
mine just broke you just broke her at
least that Mazin though you guys have 3%
Southeast Asian 2.5% Manchurian and
Mongolian okay okay okay okay well
there's more coming
okay I'm ready with cousins for sure
forty two point five percent European of
that seventeen point nine percent is
Eastern European evidence of recent
ancestry in Poland a seven point two
percent Balkan 6.5 percent Italian and
then on top of that you have one percent
French and German oh this is a common
point of confusion when we say French
and German that doesn't just mean that
you're thinking about like France and
Germany it kind of means the countries
that are really close to them like
bordering them in that area so that
includes like the Netherlands Belgium
Luxembourg Switzerland Austria so like a
bunch of countries in there are you
feeling I don't know she's not even done
here this Islam yeah I'm the most boring
my family's been all around apparently
0.6% Iberian Wow
oh my how do you feel I'm better or even
done yet nope
wait 6.6 percent Western Asian and North
African DNA most of that is Western
Asian and something we would maybe
historically have called the Middle East
includes country from Iran Iraq to
Turkey Syria places in the Caucasus
region also have point one percent
sub-saharan African heritage Courtney
cousins I feel real excited I can't wait
to tell my parents I need to save up a
lot of money take some vacation days I
need a passport
I know all right Jasmine what do you
think you know or what do you know about
your heritage I know absolutely nothing
my dad doesn't know his father
I've never met my mom's dad from the
point of my birth my dad
african-american my mom's white and so
it's been from that point on this is
what you're gonna deal with type of
thing not we're gonna go back in history
but it's like this is the problems that
are gonna be in front of you and this is
how you face them so I've never really
thought about it that much before I
guess like total wild guesses
you do have a very long list do I really
whoo you have 60.2% European ancestry Oh
12.8% of that is Eastern European 10.3%
French and German okay four point three
percent of British and Irish with
evidence of recent ancestry in the
United Kingdom oh okay
and then one point six percent Iberian
and again that Spanish in Portuguese
okay one point five percent Vulcan Wow
okay Vulcan ancestry reflects south
eastern part of Europe countries kind of
bordering the Mediterranean like Greece
or Albania Serbia Croatia you have one
point four percent Italian ancestry okay
1.3 percent Scandinavian so many yeah
and then that's your European heritage
wow that's a lot I never really like
fought into that before you have 33.5%
sub-saharan African 28.8% so most of it
is West African point nine percent East
African point three percent African
hunter-gatherers and then there's still
marks you have one point nine percent
East Asian and Native American heritage
third of that or 0.6 percent is
Southeast Asian which is pretty cool
never would I have guessed that point
two percent Native American and one
point one percent broadly East Asia and
a Native American wow we're not done
so you also have one person at Western
Asian and North African DNA 0.3 percent
of that is Western Asian some people
might describe as the Middle East
spanning from Iraq and Iran all the way
over to Turkey and Lebanon Syria and so
it could be kind of anywhere in there
and then just to wrap it up for you
point four percent unassigned that's a
lot yeah I'm everything the East Asian
and like never has that been talked
about like ever I'm just soaking it all
in I'm probably gonna overthink the [ __ ]
out of this tonight there's a bit of
really cool bunnies I feel like we all
could take a group trip cuz we're all
they get color in different areas we can
just hit every yeah that's really cool